LEIGHA JARETT: Hi, and
welcome to our session where
we're going under the hood
for Google Cloud's data
technologies.
I'm Leigha Jarett,
and I'm a developer
advocate here at Google Cloud,
and I focus on data analytics.
But today, I'm also joined
by my colleague, Derek,
who focuses on
operational databases.
Today, we're going to be
talking about two technologies.
First, Spanner on
the operational
databases side of things on the
left-hand side of our screen.
And then, we're
also going to focus
on BigQuery, our data warehouse
for analytical processing.
And these are just a few of the
pieces in the broader Google
Cloud data ecosystem.
Integrations between
both of these products
and other products
that support data
fabric, artificial intelligence,
and business intelligence
all go into making it simple for
data practitioners and business
users to power data-driven
innovation using Google Cloud.
So the story of both
Spanner and BigQuery
starts with the evolution
of the separation
of storage and compute.
Historically,
database systems have
been architected with tightly
coupled storage and compute,
so there's a dependence on
locally attached storage
because attaching
storage to a network
would result in higher latency.
But more recently,
these constraints
have been lifted, largely
due to faster networks,
which we're going to
talk about momentarily.
So now, with architecture
like BigQuery and Spanner,
we have a separation
of storage and compute,
and this allows us
to seamlessly scale
to meet your high
throughput data needs.
New compute nodes
can easily be added
to handle large
workloads, and we
don't need to rebalance the data
and ensure that a local replica
is stored on new nodes.
So let's take a closer look
at how our distributed storage
system, Colossus, is
also faster, reliable,
and cost-effective for you.
So Colossus is Google's
next generation
distributed file system.
It manages, stores,
and provides access
to all of your data for
both BigQuery and Spanner.
Its design enhances
storage scalability
and improves availability
to handle the massive growth
in data needs.
Colossus introduced a
distributed metadata model
that delivers a more scalable
and highly available system.
With all this data
stored remotely,
if a single node fails,
there's no data lost, or even
made temporarily unavailable.
Not to mention, remote storage
is dramatically cheaper
than local storage.
And the proof is in the picture.
So not only does Colossus
handle your first-party data
stored in Google
Cloud, but it also
stores the information needed
to run vital Google systems that
are used by so many
people all over the world.
Like we mentioned
earlier, the separation
of storage and
compute would not be
possible without the evolution
of networks, which increased
the speed at which compute
clusters can pull data
from storage and reduce latency.
Just like Colossus,
Google Cloud services
like BigQuery and Spanner
leverage the same network
that powers the underpinnings
of Google's systems.
And we call this
network Jupiter.
So Jupiter is made up of
an in-house custom network,
hardware and software,
and it connects
all of the servers in our
data centers together,
powering our distributed
computing and storage systems.
So we discussed our file
system and the network
that connects the storage
and compute together.
Now, leading all the
operations in our data center
is Borg, Google's internal
cluster management system
and the predecessor
to Kubernetes.
So Borg goes ahead and
provisions the needed compute
resources to handle workloads
for Spanner and BigQuery,
running hundreds of
thousands of jobs
and making computing
much more efficient.
This allows our
data centers to run
at a really high utilization.
So now, let's see how
these pieces come together
throughout the
life of your data.
So let's take a look at
Cymbal Gaming, our fake gaming
company who uses Spanner to
support transactional or OLT
workloads.
So a new user might log
into the Spanner game
and enter their information.
This data is then sent
to Colossus for storage,
but it's going to be in
Spanner's file format.
Next, this data is requested in
a query sent through Spanner's
compute engine.
And finally, the
results of the query
will be returned
in the application
to populate the new
user's profile when
they load the page.
So Spanner's storage
and compute are both
going to be optimized for
those transactional workloads.
And Derek is going to talk
more about that in a minute.
So even though Cymbal
is using Spanner
for transactional
workloads, they also
want to perform analytics
on this information
to understand how users are
actually playing their game.
But for analytical
workloads, they're
going to instead use BigQuery.
So once the user's data lands in
Spanner, they have two options.
First, they can replicate the
data in BigQuery's storage
by pushing new rows into
the native BigQuery table.
This is going to provide
optimized storage
for analytics.
On the other hand, they
can use a federated query
sent from BigQuery
over to Spanner
so that they get real-time
access to information
from their application.
Either way, they'll benefit
from BigQuery's query engine
to perform scalable
analysis, including
built-in machine
learning capabilities
that power business
intelligence reporting
and real decision-making
from business users.
So now that you understand how
BigQuery and Spanner both come
together to support
your data needs,
let's talk about how
Spanner is actually
optimized for those
transactional workloads.
So, Derek, over to you.
DEREK DOWNEY: Great.
Thanks, Leigha.
Cloud Spanner is Google's fully
managed distributed relational
database.
Spanner provides customers with
minimal operational overhead
with no downtime
for schema changes,
or even maintenance windows.
This allows Spanner to
provide an industry leading
99.999% SLA.
Because Spanner is
distributed database,
it provides seamless
replication and scaling
across regions in Google Cloud.
Spanner processes over
one billion requests
per second peak, and all of
that as a relational database
that provides strong external
consistency, made possible
by the technologies
mentioned earlier,
Borg, Colossus, and Jupiter.
To set up an example,
imagine that Cymbal Games
has developed a game that
will be played by people
all around the world.
These players must be able
to sign up, authenticate,
and play the game.
Players really don't like
to have to redo actions,
so this activity has to
have traditional consistency
guarantees.
Another thing players
don't like is downtime.
If they can't play, they get
upset, and it better be fast.
So Cymbal Games will need to
have the ability to scale up
to meet user demand.
With availability, consistency,
and scalability in mind,
let's see how Cloud Spanner can
help them achieve their goals.
When you create a
Spanner node, you
get access to Spanner resources
in three or more zones.
Zones are Borg cells.
These cells are a collection
of Spanner resources
that are physically
separate from other cells.
Spanner resources consist of
Spanner servers and Colossus
allocations of data storage,
as discussed previously.
Spanner servers provide
the compute capacity
for your cluster, and they
contain the span process,
Paxos, and other board tasks
to enable Google SREs to manage
the environment.
The zones can be within a
single region, as shown here,
or across multiple regions.
If you have a regional
configuration,
you have zones
close together that
provide the lowest read
and write latencies,
but you only get an SLA
of 99.99% availability.
In a multi-regional
configuration,
your zones are located
farther apart, which
can increase latencies,
but it provides
global scalability and an
SLA of 99.999% availability.
Now, imagine that Cymbal
Games has a table of users.
The user data is stored on
Colossus and encrypted at rest.
A copy of this data is
in at least three zones,
and replication of the rights
is handled synchronously
by Paxos consensus.
So their data will
survive zone outages
and allows for zero downtime
maintenance as well.
To understand consistency, let's
go over typical transaction
life cycles.
When a new user signs
up, Cymbal Games
issues an insert
statement to Spanner.
Since nodes exist
in multiple zones,
where the insert
statement hits depends
on which zone is the
current Paxos leader.
In this example,
zone 2 is our leader.
A single endpoint is
exposed to the client
and Spanner internals
handles routing of the query.
When the leader
receives the write,
it acquires locks and generates
a true time commit time stamp,
then, it sends the
write to other nodes
in the configuration.
These nodes write the
mutation to something
like a durable transaction
log and confirm the write
to the leader.
After a quorum of nodes
approves the write,
then the leader tells the
nodes to commit the data,
it releases the locks,
and returns the success
to the client.
All of this usually happens
within a few milliseconds.
We can't do a
session about Spanner
without mentioning TrueTime.
TrueTime is a highly
available internal service
backed by a network of
atomic and GPS masters.
This service can be called
to generate a guaranteed
monotonically
increasing timestamp
with microsecond granularity
across all nodes.
In Spanner, these timestamps
are generated for writes.
It is precisely
because of TrueTime
commit time stamps that
allows a distributed
database like Spanner to ensure
strong external consistency.
So let's see how they
are used for reads.
Once a user account
has been created,
they'd want to be able to
log in and start playing.
So Cymbal Games needs
a consistent read
to provide authentication
for the user.
In this example,
the read is going
to be executed against
zone 1 since it's
closest to the client
making the request.
But since zone 2 is
the leader, zone 1
checks in to make sure it
has the latest commit data.
If the data is the latest, it
can be returned to the client.
Otherwise, the read waits until
the node receives updates.
How does the replica know
that it has the latest data?
With TrueTime
commit time stamps.
The replica compares
its own TrueTime state
with the latest commit time
stamp to know if it's enough
up to date to serve the read.
But not all reads of the user
need to be strongly consistent.
Since user data doesn't change
that often, Cymbal Games can
choose to issue a
time-bound read,
otherwise known as a still read.
To do this, they
provide the max age
that is acceptable for their
query, making it time-bound.
This allows the Spanner
node closest to the client
to respond to the query without
incurring additional round
trip latency, communicating
with the Paxos leader.
No matter how fast
the Jupiter network
is, if you can cut out latency
across zones, you should.
With availability and
consistency covered,
Cymbal Games still needs
scalability out of Spanner.
So let's look at that.
As a first step, Cymbal
Games gets closer to launch,
they can go ahead and
increase the number of nodes
from pre-prod levels
to prod levels simply
by updating the Cloud console.
Next, as the user
data grows, Spanner
will start to create
splits of the data.
It does this both by
detecting CPU load
increases and hot spots.
And we'll split the data into
chunks to address these issues.
These splits can be hosted
on different Spanner servers
backed by different
Colossus allocations, which
helps distribute the load.
Data splits and increasing
the number of Spanner nodes
gives Cymbal Games
the ability to scale
as much as they need to.
But to avoid headaches
down the road,
they need to be sure to place
related data in the same split
using interleaving.
Imagine user activity data
that relates to the user data.
By interleaving the user
activity table with the user
table, Spanner will
change the splitting logic
to make sure that the data
stays together on Colossus.
In this way, Spanner
scales easily
while also keeping
performance high
by avoiding additional locking
required to read or write
across multiple splits.
Managing this
distributed database
for transactional
workloads is only possible
because of technologies like
TrueTime, Borg, Colossus,
and Jupiter.
So now, Leigha is going
to take it over and talk
about analytical workloads.
LEIGHA JARETT: Great.
Thanks, Derek.
So now that you understand how
Spanner is great and optimized
for transactional
workloads, let's
talk about how BigQuery's
architecture supports
analytical workloads.
So let's start by
adding the new user
data into a native
BigQuery user table.
As soon as you push data
into a native BigQuery table,
the data is going to be
transformed into a file format
called Capacitor.
Capacitor uses what we call
columnar-oriented storage,
meaning, each
column in the table
is going to be stored in a
different area of the file.
So the amount of the
columns you query
is going to be proportional
to the amount of data
that's actually scanned.
Now, if you think about it,
this is optimal for analytics
because you're often aggregating
just a few columns over lots
and lots of different rows.
Plus, each column
also has independently
compressed information.
Here, we use different
types of encoding
to optimize storage, which
makes it easier for Dremel,
our query engine, to quickly
find and use the data it needs
for your query.
Even better, you can choose
to cluster or partition
your data stored in Capacitor
so that Dremel can easily
eliminate certain files
or blocks from the query.
Let's look at a quick
example of this.
So let's say we
have our user table
and we decided to
partition based on the date
that the user was created.
We're also clustering or sorting
our table based on the game ID.
So now, when we filter our data
based on created date and game
ID, Dremel is going to use
the file headings in Capacitor
to reject the entire file
or file block if it's not
needed for the query.
This means that less data
is going to be scanned
and your query is going to
be both cheaper and faster.
So in Colossus, your data
is stored in Capacitor,
and it's going to be
automatically compressed,
encrypted, replicated,
and distributed.
So 100% of your data is going
to be encrypted at rest, just
like Derek mentioned
with Spanner.
And Colossus is also going
to ensure durability using
something called
erasure encoding, which
stores redundant chunks of data
on multiple physical disks.
So immediately, upon
writing data to Colossus,
BigQuery is going to start
this geo-replication process,
mirroring all of the
data into different data
centers around the specified
region or multi-region,
depending on how you set
up your BigQuery data set.
This means that you have
backups of your data stored
in case of disk failure
or data center outages.
OK, so we talked a little
bit about BigQuery storage.
Now, let's talk about compute.
So Dremel, BigQuery's
query engine,
is made up of
something called slots,
and these are Google's
proprietary units of CPU, RAM,
and network, and they're used
to execute the SQL queries.
So BigQuery will
automatically calculate
how many slots are
required by each query,
depending on the data size and
the complexity of the query
itself.
You can think of a
slot as a worker,
and slots are going to be
responsible for executing parts
of the active query,
independently and in parallel,
and they're going to perform
partial aggregations.
They'll also read and
write data back to storage.
So the awesome thing about
BigQuery's architecture
is that you can actually
purchase slots and reserve them
for certain workloads
in your organization.
This means that you can
scale your throughput
and your runtime as needed.
So now, let's go a little bit
deeper into query execution.
First, when you submit
a query, BigQuery
is going to break it down into
different stages, which will
be processed by those slots.
Intermediary results are
going to be written back
to what we call the
remote memory shuffle.
Since data here is
usually stored in memory,
it's really fast for slots
to read and write data
from the shuffle.
Now, each shuffled row
can be consumed by slots
as soon as it's created.
This makes it possible to
execute distributed operations
in a parallel
pipeline, which means
that we can analyze huge
amounts of data really fast.
And if a worker were to have an
issue during query processing,
another worker could
actually simply pick up
from where the
previous one left off
because they're able to read
from the previous shuffle.
So this adds an extra
layer of resilience
to failures within the
workers themselves.
OK, so let's say
we're running a query
to count how many users
joined Cymbal Games yesterday
before feeding them
into our ML model.
In the first stage
of the query, slots
will read the columnar files
from Colossus in parallel.
Each slot processes a column or
file block, filters the data,
and then writes the partial
aggregations to the shuffle.
In the next stage, a slot
reads the data from the shuffle
and combines those partial
aggregations together.
Then, it's going to write
the results back to Colossus
so that it can be served as a
cache table back to our user.
So how do these architectural
distinctions of BigQuery
actually translate to
business value for you?
Well, first of all,
we talked about how
BigQuery's optimized
storage and compute allows
for super fast queries
over huge data volumes,
meaning your business
will be empowered
to make informed decisions
without ever missing a beat.
Next, we showed
how BigQuery helps
you save money on data
storage and analysis
so you spend less
resources answering
business-critical questions.
We also talked about how
BigQuery's storage ensures
reliability and
durability, meaning
there's a very
low risk of losing
information and interrupting
business processes.
And finally, the ability to
purchase and dedicate slots
to specific workloads means you
can scale throughput and run
time so that you continue
to support your business
analytics as your data
and your use cases grow.
And don't just take
our word for it.
Google Cloud actually has
hundreds of BigQuery customers
with petabyte scale
data warehouses.
So thanks, Derek, for
walking us through Spanner.
And thank you all so
much for joining us today
to dig into Spanner and
BigQuery under the hood.
Here, we provided
some resources to help
you get started using
both Spanner and BigQuery,
and I've also
listed some sessions
that are going on at Next
related to data analytics
and databases.
So thanks again for joining us.
And we hope you
enjoyed this session,
and that you enjoy the rest of
your time spent here at Next.